here's a what
he does
whoa whoa don't don't reach for nothing
bro a New Mexico man is gunned down by
police after he pointed a rifle at
officers responding to an emergency call
don't don't reach for it
put it down put it down
it happened just before 7 pm on March
28th officials in Espanola New Mexico
responded to calls for a suspicious
vehicle they arrived on the scene to
find 56-year-old Hilario Baca in the
driver's seat of a white F-150 body
camera video shows Espanola police
officer Chris Garcia approached Baca
here's a what
if he does
don't reach for nothing bro body camera
video then shows Baca ignore the
officer's commands and point a rifle out
the driver's side window of the vehicle
that's when Sergeant James Myers opens
fire don't don't reach for it
put it down put it down
at least one bullet struck Baca moments
after the shooting officers put out a
shots fired call
[Music]
officials then call for Baca to get out
of the vehicle and show his hands
get out with your hands in the air hands
up now
get out get out of the truck now step
away from the weapon now
as the officers approach Baca they ask
why he pulled out the weapon
why'd you reach for that gun bro
huh
why'd you reach for that gun later
officials can be heard recapping what
led up to the shooting
we got called here for uh
this vehicle uh we got multiple calls
about it stated the individual was
slumped over
um
Chris rolled up first I rolled up right
behind him as soon as we got out he
started to pull this gun out the window
and started to point it towards us
wasn't listening to commands to drop the
gun to drop the gun as soon as he got
the gun all the way out the window I
I shot First Responders gave Baca
medical assistance on the scene before
he was taken to the hospital he survived
his injuries and now faces one count of
aggravated assault upon an officer from
here the New Mexico State Police is
investigating the shooting after that a
district attorney will determine whether
the shooting was justified reporting for
a long crime Network I'm Sierra
Gillespie